second and long and off right side run
and out into the open along the
[Applause]
line that's down
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
40 yards and tremendous balance to stay
in again short side of the field they do
a great job with the counter getting two
linemen out in front and he just outran
the angle
out of the pistol
it'll be Robinson and he finds a running
Lane what a sweet move
second level and Beyond touchdown Bijon
Robinson
42-yard Run
[Applause]
advertised and it's the patience he
waits for it patient as the Block's set
up and then as soon as he sees the hole
you're going to see the first past that
last level second and nine after the
one-yard pickup viewers to throw here
going for Robinson is open caught inside
the 20th a breakdown defensively and
Robinson makes another house call
41-yard touchdown for the Longhorns
thank you
loan coverage and nobody keeps sight of
Bijan Robinson looks like they're in
man-to-man coverage and nobody
identifies and goes with Bijan late by
the safety and late I'll get you beat as
Bijan Robinson
yeah it's Robinson stepping through a
tackle he's on Robinson on the gas pedal
and in
[Applause]
they see what's coming behind the
picture Dijon Robinson knows that the
front is blocked on the counter play and
he's got his eyes on one guy
number one Josh Hayes who's the
unblocked safety coming down and once he
hurtles
short time
easy money for Texas and then some
Robinson cuts inside
and he's inside the 10.
my goodness
and this is a true freshman so it's not
just throwing a true freshman right it's
blocking them they get their hands on
anyudike Usama as well and then the
Lamborghini is out
that is Billingsley
and they have just how different this
game could look right now Robinson speed
Robinson oh he's still up Robinson
inside the 15 and dragged down at the
10. this dude is a stone yards before
Logan missed another tackle just gets
wadded up a six-man box his son bounces
out there's no Kane help me out Sanders
in motion
Robinson trying to follow his blockers
reversing field Robinsons that first
step Robinson turns on the Jets and
Robinson is in touchdown number for
Bijon Robinson
Now You See Me No you don't you can't
catch him
just just a pleasure to watch watch him
press this patient press it I'm not
panicking I'm Square I'm protecting the
football I've had issues with that
earlier and then just going to speed at
the end of it finishes the video
career high 230.